[Musik]
ok jetzt erzählen euch jetzt eine
unglaubliche dichte unglaubliche
geschichte und sie handelt davon wie wir
auf die marke raspberry gekommen sind
und sie auf wahre probleme
[Musik]
bissig jetzt vor zwei jahren da war die
welt noch völlig anders war es normal
man konnte einkaufen gehen mutterfreuden
es wurde gefeiert es gab partys oder was
für party ist sagte mutter hat mich
damals im baumarkt geschickt wie immer
natürlich zum dübel holt sie weiterhin
ausnahmen
entschuldigung zu jung ihre tasche
bitte schön was für ein hübscher mann
halt stopp fassen möchten sie jubeln mir
leid lang einer verordnung nur pflanzen
und hier darum warum ist corona beim
jubeln ja es war wirklich so damals
durfte man wirklich in der pandemie im
baumarkt nur tiernahrung und pflanzen
kaufen
wenn er passt mir auf den kleinen mit
der mütze auf das ist konkurrieren aber
papa danny stam ganze kirche nahmen ein
sanierer natürlich nicht aber ich habe
keine anderen freunde die mit mir die
geschichte erzählen
natürlich wollte ihre mutter nicht
enttäuschen
[Musik]
doch was macht es
139 97 lustigen kattas
hier
nein natürlich nicht ich tue ich sowieso
alles hört mal was machen versehen
haushaltsnahe ja außer clown zu sehen
mich hat es nur gewundert wie wichtig
uns deutschen eigentlich das gärtnern
143 76
[Musik]
wenn man wissen möchte was sich der
deutsche eigentlich interessiert dann
schaut mir einfach ins
zeitschriftenregal auf platz eins
natürlich backen und kochen
auf platz zwei
wohnen wusstet ihr zb dass deutschland
für ikea wirklich der absolut wichtigste
markt ist obwohl wir nur 80 millionen
einwohner haben aber der deutsche tut
sich alle drei jahre komplett neu
erfinden
dann auf platz drei natürlich überall
drauf helene fischer das interessiert
die deutschen auch und des deutschen
liebstes hobby garten und pflanzen
entschuldigung wenn sie die zahl zu
hause auch kaufen ach ja ja ja ja ja ja
nein und mann handelt gemäß auch echte
wahl oder wer das recht mir der ist
wirklich über dem ist überall mit aber
ihr wisst ja also wie papa eben auch
schon gesagt hat der garten ist uns
allen wichtig und gerade bei uns in der
familie wisse ja auch oma und opa die
gärtnerin ja auch schon ihr leben lang
mit uns auch ich war als kind ständig im
garten der garten ist für mich einfach
so eine ruhe ort und es gibt ja wirklich
auch dinge die einem einfach gut tun und
das gärtnern und pflanzen sind eben auch
ein kulturgut und deswegen wurde uns das
tatsächlich auch während der pandemie
nicht weggenommen und aufbau des
klimawandels wird garten auch immer
wichtiger irgend gardening und garten
ist geil ich keine last müsse und garten
ist zudem lifestyle geworden ja und
deswegen war es eben wichtig dass
menschen auch während der pandemie wenn
sie nicht raus dürften zumindest zuhause
grün schaffen oder eben den garten schön
machen es gibt ja auch pflanzen die sind
einfach schön es gibt pflanzen die
riechen gut oder die pflanzen die haben
superkräfte aber recht die erste bank
super pflanzen brauchen superhelden und
unser superheld ist euro christian
niemand kann sich so gut mit pflanzen
aus wie er
betreibt eine baumschule in vierter
generation sein opa hat hier schon bäume
gepflanzt wie lang schon der ur opa war
sogar schon vor 111 jahren hat er hier
unser familienunternehmen startet genau
und christian hilft uns bei den pflanzen
er weist nämlich ganz genau was pflanzen
fühlen was ihnen weh tut und was sie
vielleicht sagen möchte das schauen wir
mal kurz drinnen oder allesklar.com
mitkommt
guck mal ich zeig dir hier was ja
das finde ich zum beispiel mega cool ja
nach krasse sieht ja aus wie so eine
krokodils hautnah ja guck mal das macht
die pflanze sogar noch wesentlich mehr
guck mal hier
ach krasser aus einer handtasche
daraus könnte man die nächste handhabe
für die sehen ja wie heißt du da jetzt
die pflanze colo
colo colo aber ich zeige dir noch mehr
gehen mit ok guck mal hier das
weißt du ja viele begeistert es war das
auch nicht weil ich inzwischen auch viel
google ja auf jeden fall weil sie das
intelligente kugel weiß ich ja so ist es
freund du bist ja ich bin froh so floh
das ist ein fehler denn theron das ist
übrigens auch nicht viel denn das ist
dieselbe gattung aber eine andere sorte
also richtig krass ich sage völlig
anders aus und ist auch baum freund weil
sie gern an baumann bäumen hochklettern
oder an regalen
du merkst einfach der baumfreunde kann
ja nicht alleine hoch wachsen der
braucht immer was wo er sich daran hält
deswegen ist er in der regel immer so
nachempfunden der stamm eingearbeitet
muss sich die pflanze hochfranken kann
und wenn du die dann im zimmer hast dann
kann das natürlich am regal oder was
auch immer entlang rein und du kennst
wirklich jeden namen jeder pflanze ja
wirklich nicht schwer ich will jetzt
doppelt schwer
okay
was ist sukkulente
nisa
und
des hat die ama
madoka ja ja das kann die die hat
richtig superkräfte ja die haben ja bei
raspberry dabei die haben ja extra dazu
genommen weil zeigt ja was denn ein
richtiger mann immer besser sagte
kleidermann geleitet
das kennst du ja schon mal die hat
wichtige inhaltsstoffe die helfen bei
der heilung die man hier also bei
verbrennungen oder so wie sie jetzt ist
ich habe hier und pickel mendig auch ein
pickel schmieren
muss das kühlt auch ehrlich ist kühlt
wirklich ja die diallo hatte
inhaltsstoffe die die kühlen die wirken
highland ihnen der haut und das sind
echte superkräfte das ist ein richtiges
naturheilmittel und sie sich auch
hervorragend der klasse dann
nächstes superkraft oder
hier pflanzen du hast ja alle gewusst
oder
bis zufrieden ich bin zufrieden aber es
ist ein hauptgeschäft wer seit 111
jahren hast du eine baumschule und von
daher kommen auch die frucht bringen und
zwar ist es eine eine sorte oder eine
art und eine marke die wir auch bei
raspberry haben und die in ihrer bäume
kommen auch von hier wo richtig rot
fleischig ist wie dieser baum hier und
gibt es eigentlich etwas cooleres als im
garten einen eigenen baum zu haben wie
willst du frischer enden als aus dem
eigenen garten egal ob obst oder gemüse
frischer als aus dem eigenen garten geht
einfach nicht der und von daher ist es
auf jeden fall nachhaltig und auch
frisch genau und diese bäume kann man
übrigens auch im kübel halten ist auch
nicht ganz ganz coole geschichte das
heißt wenn ihr zum beispiel keinen
garten habt dann könnt ihr diese äpfel
wirklich auf dem balkon kügel halten
oder was auch ganz cool ist verschenken
und das finde ich besonders cool wenn
man vorher verschenken apfelbaum und
jedes jahr wenn diese person apple
bekommt und wird ihn nach dem appell
greift rhein bei ist denkt diese
personalie euch also was ganz ganz cool
dafür gibt es unzählige anlässe ob taufe
oder
geburt wie auch immer also einfach ein
mega geschenkt
das macht natürlich der christian nicht
alleine die macht mein kumpel sebastian
und das sind wahrscheinlich die besten
pflanzen deutschlands
[Musik]
wir sind hier im hohen norden und zwar
eine baumschule an dass sie keine bäume
sag mal was ist hier los
pflanzen sind alle in den in den häusern
drin und wir haben eine ausstellung ja
und da steht alles können wir das mal
hin weil hier draußen hier auch echt ein
bisschen zu kalt ehrlich gesagt und ich
sage hier ein übrigens ich auch ja komm
schnell raus klar
[Musik]
okay
für norddeutsche ziemlich so anja
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nach diesen score ist ok also haben war
coole züchtung vorbereitet für die dann
exklusiv habt okay und ich will nicht
immer zeigen also richtig cool exklusiv
und da geht es bei uns reichen drei
große themen und zwar geht es um bei
sports and butter fleiß weil sei es
pflanzen die gut zu insekten sind für
wildbienen sind weil sie brauchen mir
ist ganz ganz wichtig ungefähr seit drei
jahren verkaufen wir zum beispiel unsere
nella april baum und da schreiben mir
manchmal leute morath ich habe dieses
jahr keine äpfel bekommen keine blüten
bekommen woran liegt es dann frage ich
immer habt ihr vielleicht bienen und
dann sagen sie herr warum wozu brauchen
wir bienen und zwar bienen brauchen wir
einfach dass sie die blüten bestäuben
dass wir äpfel haben das heißt das thema
bild wien ist ein riesen thema vögel ist
ein riesen thema insekten allgemeinen
thema das ist me spread of life ist eine
gattung die andere ist hart und ich weiß
ganz genau wie hart es ist sowas wie
menschen die eigentlich nicht mit
pflanzen umgehen können oder nicht viel
machen könnt genau irgendwie nicht die
sympathie für pflanzen haben die gehen
dann meistens in den blumenladen sagen
müssen wir mehr heimkommen sterben und
solche und solche pflanzen brauchen wir
auch und das nächste ist ein duft thema
das heißt wenn man besuch bekommt und
durch den garten läuft dann diese
gerüchte zu bekommen von ganz ganz
tollen pflanzen ok jetzt nur durch und
zeigt mir alles merken wir mal gespannt
alles klar
[Musik]
so jetzt haben wir hier schon ein
bisschen raspberry und zwar wissen diese
besonderen pflanzen diesen besonderen
kreuzungen die das wasser für uns
gemacht hat dadurch manchmal nur mal ein
beispiel zeigen
und zwar hammer hirayama anhalt bis ich
zum beispiel neu kaliß normalerweise
werden eukalyptusbäume über 100 meter
hoch das ist einer der bleibt ziemlich
klein und der ist winterhart also nicht
jeder eukalyptus der winter hat also das
besondere ist echt an dieser züchtung
und das ist nicht normal für
das ist echt eine kompakte pflanze sie
wird nicht wirklich groß das wird nicht
100 meter bahn du kannst dich schneiden
und sie ist halt winter hat das ist halt
das auch was viele denken das ist nicht
ist also das ist gut und das sind die
vorteile aus verschiedenen richtungen
werden sollten dass man sich so etwas
besonderes hat und echt schön dass so
eine richtige trend scheint sich auch
sonnige abschnitte du kannst dir man
sollte sie auch schneiden wir einmal im
jahr und und du kannst mit den essen
dann auch nun preußen machen oder mit
essig oder sowas
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt eigentlich durch die ganze
gärtnereien baumschulen du hast ja keine
saison mehr früher war es immer so in
der in den baumschulen was so dass man
eben im januar eigentlich von januar bis
märz oder im märz bis mai so richtig was
zu tun hatte inzwischen den saison
punkten war es ruhiger mittlerweile ist
es liefert fast jede woche im jahr aus
und es gibt immer schöne gehört sind die
gerade gut aussehen deswegen sind wir
immer beschäftigt
wahnsinn wichtig ist auch vielleicht
noch zu erwähnen ich hoffe dass wir
sebastian auch gehabt es gibt auch
verschiedene qualitätsunterschiede man
frägt sich vielleicht im vergleich doch
mal die preise und sagte warum kostet
das mal hier doppelt soviel wo anders
und diese qualitätsunterschiede die
durch euch ganz ehrlich wir mehr zeigen
weil die einfach so imposant sind da
haben wir zum beispiel das ist eine
potenziell und das ist jetzt so wie sie
jetzt gerade von sebastian kommen würde
also villiers jetzt bekommen im frühjahr
wenn es im frühjahr gestellt wenn er sie
erst im sommer bestellt hat sich nach
dem schon blütenblätter dran und dann
gibt's einen anderen unterschied von
zwei kosten die wahrscheinlich genauso
viel nur sitzt so aus und der
unterschiedlich ganz ganz krass diese
pflanze wurde ungefähr zwei bis drei
jahre gepflegt und diese vielleicht ein
jahr so sieht sich nach einem jahr aus
der sache raus geht und jetzt da kommt
auch dieser preisunterschied zu stande
und da kommt auch die qualität zu stande
und beim pflanzen ist es anders über
menschen und zwar man sagt ja wenn wir
noch jung ist dann ist er agil und und
alte bäume sollte man nicht verpflanzen
und alles weil planzen ist es fast
komplett anders rum und zwar umso eltern
die pflanze ist um so widerstandsfähiger
ist und wenn es so ein junges pflänzchen
hast kann es natürlich sein dass beim
ersten mal eingehen genau also die die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das ding an
werks überlebt und unschön wird ist hier
deutlich höher als bei einer ganz
kleinen pflanze die jetzt erst ein
halbes jahr alt ist also müssen diese
krassen unterschiede die weiß man wenn
man selber gärtner ist oder muss sich
mit pflanzen auskennt und da sieht man
auch diese diese preislichen unterschied
natürlich haben wir bei respekt schon
über 200 pflanzen knappe 200 pflanzen
und es gibt unglaublich viel und es ist
immer so man läuft nicht durch krasse
ich möchte ja auch haben ich möchte auch
noch haben ich möchte auch noch haben
also es ist was fürs klima ist etwas für
die natur und es ist etwa für sich
selber ist ja etwas tolles ja also dann
geht's jetzt weiter aus niedersachsen
wieder zurück
[Musik]
hey wie kommen bei raspberry heute
möchte ich euch wieder an der neue
pflanze vorstellen heute bei mir an
meiner seite jetzt wisst ihr auch warum
wir gehen zusammen die garage wochen
lang umgebaut haben und zwar um hier ein
cooles studio zu machen und in diesem
studio wird der christian ich euch
erklären den menschen erklären was was
wir pflanzen welche superkräfte haben
und beim die talentierte und beim bei
den pflanzen christian hey bei den
christen haben wir den christen in dem
muslime seien im ganzen bei den pflanzen
ich gemerkt dass wir zwar die pflanzen
haben aber auch eine richtig coole erde
dazu brauchen eine ehre auch mit
superkräften dies nicht überall geht na
ja wir haben uns ja ein bisschen
umgeguckt und haben zusammen menschen
was könnte irgendwie passen der erde
sein für unsere spray sortiment haben
aber
nicht das passende gefunden und haben
uns dann auf den weg gemacht im prinzip
eine eigene erde zusammenzustellen und
mission zu lassen damit tatsächlich auch
zu hause funktioniert einfach eine erde
mit ein paar besonderheiten drin dies so
auch nicht überall gibt eine coole in
der erde genau und beim pflanzen bei
hummer h1 gemerkt vielleicht kümmern
pflanzen zusammen ein pflanzen haben wir
natürlich auch gemerkt dass ein paar
andere utensilien noch brauchen also wie
gesagt die idee von der pflanze ist tief
im meer geworden da haben wir zb diese
coolen plays gemacht diese respekt und
die haben ihn drin zeigt mal ganz kurz
vulkangestein und dieses vulkangestein
sorgt dafür dass keine staunässe
entsteht das ist unten wirklich ein
schimmelt die gehören in jedem
kühlbereich innen oder außen und ganz
egal und sorgen einfach für eine
entsprechende durchlüftung um für eine
gute wasserabzug im außenbereich sorgen
die platz dafür dass zb man gießt dass
die erde nicht ausgespielt auch ein
kulisse also ist gleichzeitig ein track
stoffers haben das jetzt mal weil es
verhindert dass die erde unten raus geht
und hat wenn ich die töpfe die ja immer
ein loch haben müssen die makler bereich
auf einer terrasse stehen habe mit einem
empfindlichen belag kriege ich hier
durch die bleibt eben keine dreck ränder
was einen gewissen vorteil ist jetzt
noch zur erde christian was dabei
gedacht also wir haben zum einen hier
natur ton hier höher aus dem westerwald
also wir gucken immer kurze wege weil
uns das thema nachhaltigkeit ja auch
wichtig ist was macht ton ton hat die
größte oberfläche und ist daher der
ideale wasserspeicher also dass wir
einen anteil haben der einfach auf die
feuchtigkeit ein bisschen puffert was
aber keine andere erde so in der form
hat und was vielleicht gerade optisch
mega auffällt ist das hier das ist bei
nico lied ja und dieses werk hat mehrere
funktionen das ist zum einen auch ein
stückweit wasserspeicher und wenig wie
der ton kann aber noch wesentlich mehr
das war miccoli trägt das wurzelwachstum
an und ist gleichzeitig aber auch noch
wärme puffer ja das heißt dieses werk
ruit nimmt die wärme
aufhellen ähnlich mit speckstein und
gibt es ganz ganz langsam an das
erdreich ab dadurch werden einfach auch
starke struktur temperaturschwankungen
gepuffert und dann haben wir hier
natürlich noch das wo die pflanze ihre
nährstoffe raus sieht das ist grün
kompost rubio humus
was entsprechend den organischen prozess
anregt und was langsam nährstoffe kann
die pflanze ab gibt eine gewisse dauer
das heißt es ersetzt nicht dauerhaft den
dünger ganz wichtig
aber für eine gewisse zeit gerade am
anfang ist hier ausreichend nährstoffe
ufer treten durch den kompost der
einfach die nährstoffe an die pflanze
abgeben kann okay
das war echt interessant aber müssen uns
das kanal jetzt anhören ok habt ihr
rechter papa der schweizer ich habe
heute nur erklären wir machen es einfach
so wie kürzen das jetzt hier einfach ab
und ihr könnt euch ja immer wenn ihr
doch daran interessiert seid einfach die
kurzvideos auf raspberry de anschauen
und danach ein wir kürzen jetzt kurz ab
für euch fertig sollte das ist wie
gesagt die in der erde wo wir uns
überlegt haben aber wir haben auch noch
eine outdoor erde eine ganz spezielle
autor erde auch bei uns aus der region
und dazu gebraucht ich glaube du musst
mir dass sie zusammen und kräuter will
pflanzenzelle den garten schauen wir
also
wir haben wir euch ja erzählt dass es
uns bei raspberry ganz ganz wichtig ist
dass es bei euch zuhause funktioniert
sowohl indoor wie outdoor und
indoor pflanzerde haben wir ja schon
erklärt warum es so wichtig ist dass die
pflanzen ein vernünftiges glanz
fundament haben und so haben wir nicht
nur die ihn york sondern auch eine
entsprechende raspberry autor erde und
da sind einfach durch verschiedene
bestandteile drin die eben da sind damit
zum beispiel sondern süße sellerie
bronze leben und nährstoffe bekommt und
die selig später ihren sellering schon
essen kann kommen dann zeigen wir jetzt
mal wie das funktioniert
sieht es schon ganz gut wirklich wieso
eine brot backmischung da sind große und
meine bestandteile drin so ein bisschen
blähton damit die erde eben nicht so
verdichtet ist sondern einfach schön
luftzirkulation hat dass wir noch wissen
wir haben genau mit dem play ton einfach
für luft und wasser zu speichern wir
haben hier aber auch den normalen ton
gerade als wasserspeicher der permanent
mineralstoffe an die pflanzen abgibt und
richtig ist auch damit die pflanzen
guten start haben haben wir zwei
verschiedene arten von übertritten der
eine der relativ schnell wirkt
kickstarter und der andere der aber auch
die nächsten drei monate weg so dass
eure pflanzen im es moment einfach auch
gut versorgt sind in ihr euch keine
gedanken um die düngung machen muss das
kommt den ersten in der in der zeit
darauf also einfach hier eine erde für
einen guten start
für den topf für den boden und für alle
pflanzen das heißt jetzt einfach mal
einsetzen und dann hat die pflanze erst
mal alles was er braucht und bisschen
liebe und bisschen wasser und das war's
dann auch wie funktioniert das mit einem
pflanzen im prinzip indoor wie outdoor
das heißt die pflanzen die ein pflanzen
wollen einfach hier ein bisschen
aufreißen damit auch da die wurzeln nach
außen stehen und sich möglichst schnell
im erdreich festkrallen können schön die
alte ernte mäxchen abschütteln und dann
könnte die erst mal hier ein bisschen
wasser einlegen da saugt sich das noch
mal richtig voll hat
ausreichend wasser für den staat so eine
kurze zeit ist da auch gar nicht schlimm
aber es ist nett dass wir mit einem
handschuhen stückweit cooler ich wundere
mich immer warum ich ständig die nägel
machen muss also manche gehen ins yoga
und
ist sehr wichtige handschuh für die
gartenarbeit
da gibt es ganz schön poole vom rest
kann ich mir sagen lassen
[Musik]
genauso ja ok los geht's
und dann einfach ein tiefes loch bot
umgang aber
das ist alltag in gartenwerkzeug er sich
gegen die angst weil man lange nicht
mehr ja darf da natürlich recht ich
wollte euch da und wissen auf den arm
nehmen aber wobei ich sagen muss wenn
man so ein bisschen was im garten macht
markus einpflanzen trotz aller chefs
kilogramm pfannenwender aber natürlich
wenn man ein bisschen professioneller
sein möchte gibt natürlich auch profis
und als gartenwerkzeug und es kommt
tatsächlich hier aus waghäusel
wir starten jetzt hier bei der
produktion zuerst einmal mit dem holz
stehen unserer gartengeräte wir unsere
werkzeuge verwenden wir hier jetzt
europäische esche und dieses hochwertige
ausgangsmaterial wird wirklich sehr gut
kontrolliert das heißt überall wo das
holz löcher hat wo das holz risse hat
wird einfach aussortiert
[Musik]
an dieser station werden jetzt die
holzbalken gekappt
[Musik]
jetzt wird der griff noch gefräst damit
später hier noch anhänger reihen können
und damit man die werkzeuge später auch
aufhängen kann
[Musik]
oben werden die holzstühle sondern auch
ein gesägt damit später dauerhaft ein
werkzeug kopf verbunden werden kann
mein holz viele sind jetzt fast fertig
wir müssen jetzt allerdings noch feucht
geschützt werden weil gartengeräte
natürlich sehr oft mit feuchtigkeit
verbindung kommt weil sie eben auch ob
sie in der erde liegen das bedeutet das
häufig muss geschützt werden und
deswegen kommen die wallstreet mal zum
4-4-2 so eine art ölung und sie trinkt
ganz tief in folge ein schritt falls vor
der feuchtigkeit vor allem auch
langjährig und dh die holzstühle kommen
da ist im werden dann gehirn ist nicht
mehr so lang mit euch zu metall
weiterverarbeitung und zeigt euch nun
obendrauf direktverkehr gestellt wird
[Musik]
hier seht ihr schon darf die
metallverarbeitung wirklich eine sehr
sehr schwere und harte arbeit ist vor
allem im sommer denn da herrschen
wirklich ganz ganz hohe temperaturen und
es ist wirklich eine schwere arbeit bei
der man viel körpereinsatz braucht aber
eben auch ganz viel ausdauer
und egal ob acker oder axt jedes
werkzeug benötigt den richtigen schliff
um voll funktionsfähig zu sein und
deswegen gibt es hier auch wirklich sehr
gut ausgebildete und vor allem sehr
erfahrene mitarbeiter die das erledigt
ja
[Musik]
zurückziehen holz stehe hier haben wir
jetzt die holzstühle die jetzt noch
verschönert werden und zwar werden die
dann lackiert mit umweltfreundlichen und
und auf wasserbasis konzipierten lacken
und diese arbeit die zielgerade
verrichtet hat früher zum beispiel meine
tante schon am gleichen ort verrichtet
[Musik]
und hier sind die holzstühle dann schon
an ihrer letzten station und werden
gelasert und bekommen so unser schönes
raspberry logo auf jeden griff
[Musik]
wir stehen jetzt sozusagen kurz vor der
hochzeit denn hier werden die ganzen
dinge miteinander verheiratet wir haben
hier einmal dem holzstiel und die
werkzeug köpfe und bei den werkzeugen
ist natürlich wichtig dass die bücher
miteinander verheiratet werden damit
beim arbeiten eben der haken kopf nicht
einfach wegfällt und dafür brauchen wir
jetzt holz und stahl ring keine und die
werden dann so angebracht dass es
werkzeug eben sicher auf dem holz still
sitzen bleibt der holzkeil sorgt für die
cam wirkung und der stahlring keil der
verstärkt und maximiert eben diese klemm
werbung wenn sie ein pärchen leben nur
auch so einfach mehr
[Musik]
und wenn die werkzeuge dann einwandfrei
sind werden jetzt noch die details im
acessoires angebracht verpackt und in
unser lager verschickt
[Musik]
und beim einpflanzen können dann einfach
nur darauf achten dass die pflanzen
nicht zu tief in die erde gesetzt wird
sondern wirklich maximal so wie sie
vorher eben auch im pflanzgefäß war
[Musik]
hat er hunger hat man ich geb dir kurz
was der green
it schon jetzt kurz essen und zu haben
wir erzählen noch fertig und später
gibt's was für dich
haben wir menschen brauchen ja auch
nahrung und genauso brauchen auch eure
pflanzen im autobereich natürlich nach
zweimal im jahr soll insel deswegen
gedüngt werden und dafür haben wir einen
ganz speziellen biodünger entwickelt der
ganz natürlich organisch unserer egal
ist und das bedeutet dass ihr da weg sie
auch gar keine angst haben müsste wegen
kindern oder zum beispiel tieren im
garten kann man auch ein kleines
schweinchen kommt mini monet schau mal
guck mal hier
und es ist wirklich so ein dünger der
für alles ist da ist alles drin wirklich
alles in einem und einer für alles da
braucht ihr keine speziellen anderen
dünger mehr für den rasen oder für die
pflanzen oder die kräuter oder das
gemüse und das wendet ihr einfach
zweimal im jahr an und wir brauchen
wirklich ganz wenig nur davon und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier mal so einen
vergleich also ich habe hier einen 5
liter eimer erreicht nur 165
quadratmeter schon eine große menge ihr
braucht praktisch nur diese 30 gramm
also wirklich nicht mal ein viertel
teglas voll für einen quadratmeter und
hier seht ihr mal den unterschied das
ist wirklich 150 gramm auch für einen
quadratmeter also schon eine ordentliche
menge die man da hat man hat irgendwie
nur ein fünftel von dem was man
herkömmlich braucht und hat doch
wirklich schön den rasen gedrückt von
der dünger ist eben ganz natürlich eher
könnten tatsächlich auch einfach mit den
händen verteilt und was ich ganz gut
findet dadurch dass er veganes ist da
eben auch sonst keine bestandteile von
tieren drin das heißt euer rasen oder
garten oder stinkt danach noch
genau also die pflanzen draußen können
sie auf jeden fall mit dem eimer füttern
für den innenbereich also für alle
pflanzen die innen im haus stehen bei
auch bei euch im kinderzimmer da muss
etwas anderes überlegt da haben wir im
kleinen paulchen zusammengearbeitet
haben die köpfe zusammengesteckt und
etwas richtig schönes ganz ganz tolles
futter
ist das normal heute habe ich einfach
mal jünger also sagt wie die pflanze
gehört alles was sie brauchen um gesund
und lange leben zu können oder was immer
schlechter ich will ja auch perfekt also
sozusagen eine pflegeserie für pflanzen
genau das wohlbefinden und die
gesundheit mehr okay wir können anfangen
mit dem bürger dieser ist ja bei der
pflanze wie beim essen für menschen und
da tun wir eigentlich muss lästereien
und das praktisch für in deutschland
genau also dass für ihn die pflanzen
aber du kannst du auch autor benutzen
wenn es mal schnell gehen muss weil der
dünger hier der wirkt innerhalb von zwei
bis drei tagen schon wenn der franz da
wird über das wasser mit aufgenommen
übers wasser gegeben und kommt dann
direkt oben an wohin soll das heißt wenn
ich merke die pflanze die brauchen
einfach ein bisschen nährstoffe direkt
hier ein bisschen dünn und dann weiß ich
kommt sofort an und was haben wir denn
da so alles drin da sind der seite drin
also die werden abgebaut und diesen auch
komplett freie zum beispiel von
schwermetallen und die werden dann
zusammen gemixt in der speziellen
rezeptur dass man halt auch alle
nährstoffe in den finger drin hat also
nicht nur ein sondern vor allem etwas
und das wird damit wasser bei uns dann
in der fabrik verdünnt und dann machen
wir das ganze später kommt das viele
wasser verdienen und dann im blut geben
hol das machen wir jetzt mal kannst mir
einen von denen raussuchen
da kann es mal ungefähr so viertel von
dem reagenzglas mit ihm offen
das macht man jetzt sein
dass man können wir das ganze mal gut
durchschütteln und damit stellen wir
dann sozusagen unsere lösung her seit
sie sind vorher ausgesucht wurde gesagt
dass wir die richtige rezeptur haben und
dass sie sich auch sehr gut lösen das
heißt wir haben nicht wie in anderen
branchen und wohnen absatz besonders
lustig dann kommt wird
und dann haben wir noch den blockbustern
ist er praktisch dann wenn man es nicht
über die wurzel machen möchte sondern
direkt über das platz genau zum beispiel
bisschen urlaub gefahren hast zwei drei
wochen nicht gedüngt und dann haben wir
hier so kleine gelbe flecken auf drauf
die blattadern komm raus sie haben
hunger und brauchen ganz schnell ganz
dringend wie sonst musik und dann haben
wir auch wieder salze gefunden die
werden nicht nur die wurzel aufgenommen
so das blatt und haben wir speziell
zusammengemischt und dann können wir bei
so einer situation die blätter damit
einfach einsprühen
unternehmen die das schöne was kleiner
unternehmen das schön was bleibt auch
das können wir drei vier tage später
nochmal machen und dann wird man schon
ersten erfolg sehen dass die blätter
wieder schön richtig und grün werden und
die blattadern ich muss raus gucken
mit dem paulchen zusammensetzt geratenen
essen so tan und zwar könnt ihr euch das
so vorstellen es gibt ja schädlinge es
gibt spinnmilben es gibt blattläuse und
esse so ist was ganz natürlich ist das
einfach schön zusammen gemixt wird damit
eben schädlinge wegbleiben und vor allem
steckt eben auch die pflanzen
[Musik]
wir rühren hier unsere nesselsucht dann
geht's auf den pflanzen gleich wieder
gut 6
[Musik]
ursprünglich trinken haben ja mal was
für dich
ja so wie eigentlich auch wasser für
euch wichtig ist das wasser mit sich
auch ein thema was für pflanzen ganz
wichtig ist ich meine keine pflanze
überlebt ohne wasser und ich möcht ich
liebe meinen garten ich liebe auch
meinem haus weil ich liebe meine
pflanzen im indoor bereich aber ich habe
auch nicht jedesmal zeit muss ich sagen
und auch die muse alle pflanzen ständig
zu gießen und opa und oma sind zwar auch
immer da und helfen uns der papa ist ja
auch gern den garten aber ich muss auch
sagen dass eine regelmäßige bewässerung
gerade im garten echtzeit sei wichtig
ist und haben wirklich ganz ganz tolle
ideen und zwar haben wir hier den tri
hager und wofür die haager dann braucht
es zeige euch jetzt ganz einfach oftmals
ist bei uns im sommer so momentan haben
wir gerade 38 grad und ich hoffe hier
damit position lange hose aber oftmals
ist so man mit dem baum gewässern und
dann nimmt man sich einen gartenschlauch
wenn wir keine bewässerungsanlage hat
und mussten beim bewässern jetzt ist es
so wenn die erde unterm baum richtig
trocken ist wirklich so dass wenn dieses
was drauf kommt dass es sofort im
erdreich versickert das heißt die ganzen
baumwurzeln werden gar nicht durch
weshalb piccola wäre es möglich eine
viertelstunde da sitzt und eine
viertelstunde lang den baum richtig
verbessert dass das wasser das die
wurzeln möglich nass werden und dafür
haben wir den trainer im entwickelt und
ich zeige euch jetzt mal kurz
zur ihk heißt umarmen diese bewässerungs
sagt umarmt den baum
und wird jeden einfach im reißverschluss
festgemacht
aber der tri hager ist nicht einfach nur
ein bewässerungs sowie ihren vielleicht
kennt die funktions und bewegungstag und
zwar nimmt ihr einfach einen
gartenschlauch und wir könnten hier
eröffnen
und einführen
und zwar ist das problem bei den meisten
bewässerung säcken wirklich so dass er
nach zwei drei stunden komplett entleert
ist aber wir möchten ja dass es wasser
wirklich langsam tropft die meisten
säcke haben hier unten löcher und dh des
baskischen 23 stunden komplett leer wir
möchten aber das ist länger besser das
heißt das wasser wird nicht so langsam
tropft dass die wurzelballen richtig gut
durchfeuchtet sind deswegen haben wir
hier
komplett gewinnziele gebaut das ist ein
patent von uns eine richtig coole
geschichte und hier kann man dieses
ventil die durchflussmenge einstellen
und entscheiden wie schnell der sachsen
lernen soll einfach noch ein bisschen
technik in den garten reingebracht und
wäre auch nicht damit aufgehört und zwar
haben wir auch endlich mal hier diesen
jumping jack das besondere an diesem
jumping jack ist jeder kennt es sonst
kann man meistens nur eine saison nach
der ein solcher kaputt und wir haben uns
überlegt wie kann man so einen jumping
jack noch cooler machen und haben uns
überlegt man kann hier an den seiten
kann man solche schnellen hinbauen
und man hat nicht platzsparend was aber
auch geht beim jumping jack ich mache
ganz auf zack zack hoch
so ist zb wenn man draußen stehen hat
dass man auch wirklich komplett zu
machen kann so und das sind nur ein paar
ideen von vielen vielen weiteren
produkten und diese produkte entstehen
wirklich aus der praxis heraus man merkt
einfach in der praxis wenn man garten
arbeitet was braucht man man braucht
langlebige sachen nachhaltigkeit ist
qualität mit dem jumping jack nimmt die
hacker haben wir definitiv zwei coole
produkte die man auf jeden fall ganz
cool im garten gebraucht haben so jetzt
hatten wir unsere pflanzen wir hatten
unsere erde wir hatten unser werkzeug
unter selbstgemachten eigenen dünger wir
hatten nicht alles aber garten soll auch
lifestyle seien es 53 design seiner
funktionieren genau und dafür dafür
haben wir eure nannte ally
ich hab's euch gesagt hey junge frau
habe bisher schon näher kommt schnell
auf aber was machst du musst mir die
pflanze mit draufpacken wieder hier ja
die brauchen uns als dekor ihren
vorsichtigen
was auf
halo ist
ich muss jetzt noch die ganzen
blumengießen alles was machst du jetzt
noch nicht mal ich hab noch ein paar
coole sachen ich habe mich ein paar
coole ich zeige das okay aber aber
keinen schon allein keine scheiße ich
hoffe ich wusste ja wissen
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt am grillplatz hier und
ich gebe euch einen kleinen einblick in
mein alltag wie ich hier dekoriere ich
dekoriert zwar nicht jeden tag aber es
ist trotzdem teil meiner aufgabe und ich
will ein bisschen inspiration geben wie
ich heute mit den grenzen von raspberry
umgehe und die deko artikel nutze das
heißt kommt einfach mal mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay ich hab was ich glaube was wir
wollen das ist ein surfer und zwar ich
habe breite und 1 2 haben die trommeln
saumäßig cool ich habe seit ewigkeiten
steht eine garage bei der häuslichen
also ich fand meine garage wird das
besser passen da ist über den vc garage
das heißt ich fahre hier
ist ehrlich kommt
es gibt
halt nicht
sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe mich für möglich ich habe es
vorhin schnell gesehen von oben der
hammer komposition das ist richtig
gemütlich auch die ganzen farben passen
sondern das ist racing genauso haben wir
vorgestellt und sie liebe kinder das ist
eure tante ella ist richtig toll drauf
mit dem ganzen design die hat wirklich
das auge für alles hier und serien laden
hier zusammen sie ist head of race berry
und sie kümmert sich um alles und wir
werden noch viel spaß zusammen haben sie
an ihr wisst ja wenn wir was machen wir
fühlen uns einfach immer richtig wenn in
der küche stehe da brauchen die
küchenschürze wenig karaokesingen
brauche ich irgendwie im kostüm und wenn
ich im garten bin dann fühle ich das
einfach auch richtig das heißt ich habe
im garten daneben auch immer kleidung an
die mir gefällt da ich mich wohl fühle
ich mich aber auch frei bewegen kann
deswegen habe ich da immer latzhosen an
weite hosen kursen die mir vielleicht
auch nicht runter rutschen wenn ich mich
mal bücken muss und was ein pflanzen
möchte und einfach etwas was salisch
aussieht aber eben auch bequem ist und
so haben wir uns dann irgendwann auch
überlegt warum machen wir nicht
eigentlich auch unsere eigene raspberry
textilien warum machen wir nicht
kleidung die stylisch ist funktional
sozusagen arbeitskleidung aber auch für
jedermann für jede körpergröße für jeden
das passende und so kam eigentlich auch
die tante fatma ins spiel denn fatma ist
schon seit über zehn jahren designerin
bei boss und tante vater hatte da
wirklich geniale ideen die sie mit uns
ausgearbeitet hat
also das sind jetzt die letzten
musterteile genau die latzhosen die wir
in langen den kurz haben und wo wir auch
gesagt haben wir wollen hier kein
elasthan drin so wirklich 100 prozent
baumwolle
ich find's ganz cool ich bin es auch
ganz cool dass wir da viele farben haben
dass wir denen lang- und den kurz
gemacht haben und es ist halt einfach
ein teil was man noch jeden fall im
garten tragen muss aber ist es
normalerweise auch immer solche wir
hatten jetzt schon ich würde mal sagen
seit beginn bis jetzt sind wir schon
sofas bei einem halbjahr also von der
ersten idee über wir wollen dass jedes
unserer textilien irgendwie einen blumen
namen trägt und für flipchart findet in
verschiedenen blumennamen bis hin zu den
fertigen muster teilen dass man jetzt
echt eineinhalb jahren viele muster
gingen hin und her schnitte anpassungen
die latzhosen vor allem dass die da
vorne ebenso diese hat die brust schönen
bedenken das ist auch ganz wichtig ganz
wer
in der textilindustrie immer so dass man
da so lange laufzeiten hat oder ist
jetzt bei uns wahrscheinlich weil wir
einfach uns erst mal zurechtfinden
werden ich glaube das war auch so unsere
freiheit das gar nicht so dass druck da
war zu sagen okay
man drop jetzt die kollektion man hat
eigentlich so eine entwicklungszeit von
zwei bis drei monaten und dann entstehen
musste und dann nachdem die muster
entstehen wird es dann auch produziert
und wir hatten ja total freiheit also
wir haben ja wie du sagst wir haben da
wirklich sehr detailliert rande arbeitet
also allein der name von den styles war
uns wichtig das logo wird platziert und
wie du sagst
ich möchte das teil auch mal kurz in die
wäsche schmeißen schauen wie
reagiert der stoff auch und bei solchen
sachen
genau warum haben wir da ganz gut
feststellen wer in der firma
waschen kann und wer nicht fit war
schien ja das war eigentlich echt aus
und selbst versucht er sich denn wir
haben praktisch getestet wie die
textilien sich verhalten wenn sie einmal
gewaschen werden zwei mal 10 mal und
zwar ganz witzig zu sehen manche waren
sowie dem hilflos aber da haben wir dann
direkt seine wäsche routine so ein
bisschen info infos mit weitergegeben
dass da eben jeder gut aufgehoben ist
wäsche waschen
[Musik]
er ist schon wahnsinn oder was auch von
einem kleinen dübel entstanden wären
ja gleich gehts zum grillen hier mit
unserem team und was sie jetzt hier die
letzte stunde gehört habt es ist unsere
geschichte von raspberry zusammen
letzten zwei jahre geschlossen und ich
freue mich riesig dass ihr heute mit
dabei war ich hoffe euch gefällt unsere
geschichte die heute hier erst mal
startet wie gesagt seit zwei jahren
arbeiten wir dran aber ab heute geht es
richtig los und ich hoffe begleitet uns
auf diesem weg aus berlin und jetzt
gehts franz grill und sparsam ja also
euch vielen dank dass ihr mit dabei war
auch beim live chat wir gehen jetzt hier
noch grillen jetzt dürft ihr euch gerne
noch auf ein paar outtakes freuen denn
es läuft in tennis welt nicht immer
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
ok
sie sind jetzt ein grillplatz und
ilja sagt bitte nochmal bitte sag und
ich gebe jetzt einen kleinen einblick in
unsere sind jetzt am grillplatz und ich
wir sind jetzt im griff habe ich an mir
gepackt
gibt es auch
männer kleidung
nur frauen arbeiten im garten
ich muss gleich links rum auf das
gericht
[Gelächter]
du wirst gebraucht hast du ich mag keine
story hinzu coal dran war der ganz
kristek damals die schule aus
nachher wirklich da auch gott sie das
hässlich aus
nicht so ganz
was für meine muskulatur
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hängt
die
[Gelächter]
vorgaben gemacht doch das was im
drehbuch steht
die bibel wirklich eigentlich laut einer
verordnung mascola ordnung
[Musik]
coca cola
[Gelächter]
okay weil ich mache das
nicht gewohnt
in der kuga ob es ja nicht so
schneiden wie
ein schlag
[Musik]
werbung
der ton war von der gute ton
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ballaballa
ich hab mal
grundschule erinnern
jetzt macht sie youtube im internet
macht sie videos zu koche und backe
erfolgreich
ich muss nichts mehr schaffe ich
[Gelächter]
das jetzt auf den kindern im fußball die
spielerfrau
daliah auch sauber wischen saugen
staubsauger über als sauger
könnt ihr das bitte an seine mutter
schicke mit übersetzung danke an die
fans von
michael
profis geht in deutschland in allen
ja ich fand
es wird gearbeitet
mailands fürs internet